à guyancourt ville de 29000 65 habitants
quatre candidats s'opposent
grégory pape tête de liste de nouvel
élan à guyancourt ce pharmacien de
profession habite la commune depuis 2012
est également représentant d'élèves
l'homme politique se lance dans sa
première campagne lors de ces
municipales 2020 nous sommes lancés il
ya un an nous avons commencé un travail
de terrain à aller à la rencontre des
habitants de guyancourt avec un premier
questionnaire suite à ce premier
questionnaire nous avons identifié les
grands thèmes qui interroge l'aiguillon
courtois sur ces grands thèmes nous
avons construit des ateliers
participatifs
nous en avons fait la synthèse pour pour
rédiger nos programmes deuxième liste
ensemble agissons pour but en cours
menée par rodolphe baril l'homme
politique de 58 ans a notamment été
scolarisé au collège paul eluard
il a été maire adjoint
voisins-le-bretonneux de 2008 à 2014 et
conseiller communautaire le début de
l'histoire en fait c'est c'est un
certain nombre d'amis duo courtois avec
qui j'ai échangé et fort de mon
expérience mon écoute tu a le profil
pour être tête de liste est ce que tu
voudrais pas être notre tête de liste
pour monter un projet sur le en cours
donc voilà ça c'est fait aussi
simplement que ça donc je mets à profit
mon expérience d'ancien et vu l'ancien
maire-adjoint d'anciens conseillers
communautaires au profit des gluants
courtois troisième liste décidons
ensemble à guyancourt une liste
participative menée par olivier paréja
un ingénieur de 54 ans qui habite le
quartier du village cet homme politique
à la sensibilité écologique virgule en
cours depuis 2008
c'est ce qu'on m'a confié d'être tête de
liste en fait pour nous ça veut surtout
dire porte parole d'un collectif
donc ça veut dire que c'est pas
nécessairement celui ou celle qui va
tout décider mais plutôt quelqu'un qui
est mis en avant parce que le
fonctionnement actuel d'une liste d'une
municipalité est comme ça mais c'est pas
notre fonctionnement naturel nous on
voudrait faire quelque chose de beaucoup
plus collectif de où tout le monde peut
participer quatrième et dernière liste
guyancourt pour tous ceux 2020 une liste
menée par le maire sortant de la commune
françois morton l'homme de 50 ans a été
auparavant premier adjoint au maire en
charge de l'éducation de la jeunesse et
de la politique de la ville sur le plan
professionnel il est enseignant
spécialisé
j'assume parfaitement ce bilan ce bilan
il est encore une fois apprécier un
propos pour rencontrer très
régulièrement et au quotidien l'ensemble
des années des habitants de l'ue en
cours je sais qu'ils apprécient
effectivement les actions et les
réalisations mises en place durant ce
dernier mandat c'était déjà le cas dans
les mandats précédents mais il s'avère
que je n'étais pas élu à l'époque donc
je mais j'assume totalement ce bilan et
on en est particulièrement fier